2023 verá el primer torneo de Roland
garros sin Rafael Nadal desde hace 19
años se hace imposible así se expresó el
tenista español desde manacor en una
rueda de prensa donde confirma una
decisión que muchos temían tras su
ausencia de las pistas desde enero al
sufrir en Australia una lesión en la
pierna izquierda nada al de casi 37 años
pone un punto y aparte en su carrera con
una pausa que espere le deje volver a
competir al más alto nivel a finales de
año dejará de jugar y de entrenar al
tenis unos meses para permitir Así que
su cuerpo se regenere Twitter se llenó
de reacciones al anuncio del ganador de
22 grandes slams el comité olímpico
español augura que su ausencia de París
era Solo Una pausa en el éxito mientras
que Roland garros afirma que le
extrañarán este año y que esperan verle
en 2024 algunos de los grandes del tenis
como Carlos alcarazo medbeth número 2 y
3 respectivamente le han deseado su
pronto regreso y es que su escasa
participación este año supondrá una
caída Más allá del puesto 130 en la
clasificación ATP en la que ahora ocupa
el número 14 Así que nada al regresar
tendrá dos opciones para poder competir
o que la inviten o apelar al ranking
protegido una opción para los tenistas
lesionados en cuanto a su posible
retirada en 2024 este parece un tema
tabú en España pocos quieren especular
con lo que nada el anunció que es su
intención nadie quiere adelantarse a los
acontecimientos ni Rendirse ante esta
opción una lección aprendida del
arteacidad del tenista español que
aseguró que espera que su despedida no
sea en una rueda de prensa